hello everyone
i'm everyone eric welcome to streaming
analytics on google cloud
when you look at idc they predict by
2025
more than a quarter of the data in the
global data sphere will be real time in
nature
now you may wonder why is this important
it is important because
windows opportunity in the real-time
analysis
diminishes and goes away really fast
you want to be able to actually respond
to your customer needs
their asks maybe do product prediction
or maybe detect some problem
and really respond to really fast while
each and every one of this data
becomes valuable for retrospective
analysis
time to respond in a real time is very
limited
so you want to have a platform that you
can achieve both of these
real time as well as a place where you
can do retrospective analysis
and for that you have streaming
analytics on google cloud
and this is the platform many of you out
there are already
providing various solutions in your
industries
you have pops up on one end the
google native service that entire
alphabet company takes advantage of
we made it available through gcp for you
to take advantage of as well
and you're doing a great job in there
that is your ingestion and distribution
of data reliably globally
and you have data flow for you all your
data processing
whether it's streaming or batch now you
can do that
and as you know in data flow it's the
same set of code for both streaming
and batch and then you have the ai
platform bigquery bigtable cloud sql
all of them are there for your machine
learning needs for your ai needs
and data warehousing needs to do more
analysis
for your businesses here are some
examples
the great success stories home depot
when they started their journey
on the digital transformation when they
wanted to establish this e-commerce
platform for themselves
they picked pops up dataflow and
bigquery to do this thing
and this enough allowed them to really
increase new revenue opportunities and
reduce their churn
when you look at palo alto networks
they're building their next generation
firewall
using dataflow as an embedded data
processing system
airasia used the streaming analytics
platform
to provide refined pricing for their
customers
this allowed them to increase their
revenue and improve customer
satisfaction
and customer experience ultra beauty has
established their
e-commerce platform where they can
actually provide real-time offers to
their users
and suggestions based on their shopping
practices and search practices and so
forth
again using this real-time analytics
platform for their
shoppers now in this platform
in your own organizations you have some
heroes out there
your data analysts your engineers your
data scientists and your
operators are out there making this work
for your
systems for your customers and
throughout my conversation today with
you
i'll be highlighting what we're doing to
make their lives easier
more effective and also bring some cost
saving opportunities
for all of you out there here's a
snapshot of what you're going to hear
for the rest of my talk you will hear
data flow sequel
we're actually really happy all the
feedback that we've gotten from you on
the early releases
you're loving this thing it made it much
easier for your
analysts and engineers you're really
enjoying the ai platform integration
with data flow and jupyter notebooks was
one of those things that data scientists
really really asked for it
and here you go you have an integrated a
seamless experience
from many of our services on google
cloud including data flow
and operators have asked for some
dashboards some real-time analysis
capabilities
and a lot more in here we're going to go
into it ready
let's go let's start with the ingestion
first
i mentioned pops up is one of those
services that we across alphabet
leverage and we made it available it's a
globally scalable fantastic technology
really really good we did hear loud and
clear from all of you that you wanted
message ordering and dead other topics
and thank you for your patience now
they're going to be available for you
we also heard some cost saving
opportunities where you
ask for a service like pop stop light
i'm going to go into a little bit more
and it gives you cost optimized event
ingestion and data messaging platform
for your zonal needs very global nature
may not be necessary
for you so we created in here our
objective was to make it
so compelling even for your do yourself
kafka
solutions that you may have is going to
be a higher cost than what we can
provide to you
and of course through our confluent
cloud partnership
we have a fully managed kafka service
for all your on-prem to cloud migration
needs
and cdc was one of those capabilities
that you've been asking for
and i'm going to give you a couple
examples of what is coming up for you
here's a pop stop lights so this is
possibly the lowest cost to serve
possible
uh messaging and event messaging system
that you can find in here
it's ideal for predictable workloads
it's zonal
so that you can actually figure out
where to do it it's really easy to
uh configure and already seamlessly
integrated with data flow
rest of google cloud data analytics
platform and gcp services
so give it a try if you haven't used it
we
believe it will be much easier for you
to really take advantage of puff
sublight
than do it yourself like environment
that you may have
if you have a lot of kafka workloads
and you are migrating to google cloud
you are using or you should be using
confluent cloud we've seamlessly
integrated with our partners
they're integrated just like pops up
with data flow and our other
gcp services for you to achieve your
kafka workloads and
as you're migrating towards gcp and cdc
this was your ask and here's a two
option for you that we're actually
uh providing you and for your mysql and
postgres
uh use cases we're building a solution
with the museum it's available as an
open source self-managed templates
as a fully managed template solution
from ourselves
we're bringing you through our data
stream you will have a cdc capability
for oracle databases through data stream
through data flow to bigquery you'll be
able to provide the cdc capability
this has been one of those asks and
we're happy to show you what's coming up
for you
for our data engineers and some pipeline
development that's key
i highlighted the area flow sql it's for
you to really take advantage of
sql it's the same uh dialect that we
have with
uh our bigquery and spanner you'll be
able to do
kind of joins within the pops up streams
and bigquery tables and gcs files and so
forth
you'll do some schema supports using the
visual editor it's right there for you
the early responses was very very
positive if you haven't started using it
i encourage you to really take a look at
it you'll be able to build your
real-time dashboards
based on bigquery do your transforms
it's right there
very easy go at it if you haven't
started using it
data scientists have been asking for
this jupyter notebook integration with
data flow
so that you can actually do your own
interactive development
uh prototyping in the environment that
you're so used to it
now data flow is integrated into jupyter
notebooks
go ahead and do it you have the
interactive runners there
all the supported in it for your ai
platform
on google cloud it's the same experience
so this was something you've been asking
for i'm really happy to
announce that it is in your hands now
this is a good one flex templates as you
know
we provide 25 different templates
through our data flow ui and cli for you
to take advantage of as a template
one of the asks that many of you had was
hey
i built these data flow pipelines into
my
system but i want to turn this into a
template so rest of my organization can
use it as well
within my own team within my own
organization
now you can do that this was something
that you asked for
it's a much better uh system and you're
used to it you create it
it's all yours along with the 25 that we
provided
quick recommendations this is this is a
it's a really interesting uh capability
so it actually provides you
guidances for your data analysts data
engineers data scientists and it
achieves some cost saving along the way
where you can actually get some
recommendations hey do it this way and
do it that way maybe clean your data
store databases or
entities find different ways to really
storage
and backup and resource spanner what
have you it provides you
through these recommendations ways to
really improve it what is it that you
can do
and this is all in the fingertips of
yours
performance is scale this is always a
paramount for us
it's always top of mind we always figure
out a way to make it
faster easier and scale even bigger and
broader
here's one flex rs if you haven't heard
this
is a fantastic cost saving opportunity
for you
you could save up to 40 of your cost
in some of your batch workers if you
have a job
that you run daily or weekly you don't
have to worry about changing a single
line of codes
all you have to do is turn it on add one
pipeline option
that's it but remember this needs to be
one of those jobs
that you run daily or weekly because it
might take a few hours to find the most
cost optimum
environment for it to run so that's why
it says in here it may delay up to six
hours
here's what we have done for the beam
community the data flow runner v2 is
available
it has a lot more uh capabilities in
there from
more ios including kafka io and so forth
to
parity across sdks some including the
state and timer support in python
it's available right now for you to test
with your python
streaming pipelines go at it and try it
you will find some cost saving
opportunities there
all of you data engineers out there and
thank you for really taking advantage of
the beam
and our operators for you you've been
asking this
dashboard now all your important
pipeline measures in a single time
correlated dashboard is ready
it's available for you you'll be able to
go deep time into it
understand how we're making some of
these auto scaling decisions that was
some
somewhat of a mystery for all of you and
you've been asking for it so we're
providing some of these visibilities
and it's just some cost uh reductions as
well so you can optimize your own
pipelines latencies and troopers that
you're going at it
and these are all in your fingertips and
keep asking keep pushing us
in this area manage pipelines this is
another one
that you've been asking now you'll be
able to understand the resource
allocations over multiple job executions
that you may have
this actually enables you to really give
you better freshness on the slash
solos and so forth drill down on your
pipelines
maybe figure out some problems that you
may be seeing at the end and fix it and
optimize it
it's much easier for you to do it we're
going to continue to invest in here
ease of use paramount for us we really
really uh want to make it easier for you
now real-time ai as an ai student i'm
always excited about what we're doing in
here
so we've been working with
our with our partners across the uh uh
ecosystem and trying to figure out what
is that we can do and how is it that we
can actually create some patterns
and create some uh kind of easy to start
templates and sample codes and so forth
uh by integrating data flow and cloud ai
platform
for pattern recognition anomaly
detections and predictions and
forecasting and so forth
for every industry you can think of from
media
to retail to healthcare to
fintech you name it there's some great
capabilities out there
you can use structured and unstructured
data for your paleontic
recognition you can use it with your
videos you can use it with images and
text
and so forth now here's an example from
telus
a great team uh in canada they're one of
the largest and fastest growing telecom
companies
and they have many many events coming in
and they wanted to actually use data
flow to detect some
anomalies in their network so we're
looking at 250 000 events per second
that they process and they figure out
are there any anomalies that we need to
be really looking at it and detect it in
a timely manner
and respond to it this is one of those
use cases where you really need to
detect
fast and respond fast and telesteem has
done a fantastic job
taking advantage of this platform these
capabilities that we provided with
dataflow
and there's a lot more to do there you
can do it in every industry
if you visit our website you will see a
lot more in there
and the codes are ready for you to take
advantage of from github
let's wrap it up together we are the
leader in
seeing analysis when you look at
forrester's seeming wave
there are a lot of things that makes us
the leader in this area there are
five criteria that we've been rated the
highest in here
many of you are already taking advantage
of these capabilities
and we invite all of you to come take a
look at it
visit ping us chat with us
there's a way we can help you with all
your needs in here
here's a list of you up there doing
wonderful things
in everywhere in the world from retail
to transportation from healthcare to
gaming
to media to fintech although we have
built
great solutions on these technologies
that i just talked about
thank you for everything that you're
doing thank you for all your use cases
and challenging us and working with us
we're looking forward to really
hearing more of your feedback we're here
to really work with you
here's a wrap up for you we talked about
what we've done for data analysts data
engineers data scientists and operators
there's a lot more
out there if you go and visit our
streaming analytics
uh websites in google cloud you will
find
many blogs many links to the uh code
repositories and so forth to really make
it easy
but if you still have a problem pingas
ping me find me
wherever you can just we'll get you
going right away
thank you for your time really
appreciate it and
hope you had a wonderful time